man I cannot believe I'm about to say
this a Montreal based law firm has filed
a request for a class action lawsuit
against epic games the careers of
fortnight and according to them the game
is as addictive as cocaine and
cigarettes
all right so the framework for this
lawsuit is based around the case studies
of two unnamed children one of these
children is 10 years old and the other
is 15 and over the past two years they
both had increasingly addictive
relationships with Fortman
the suit is being filed by a law firm
called collects legião and the lawyer on
the case is a woman named Alessandra
Esposito sure sure Alessandra Esposito
sort ran the firm was contacted by the
parents of these two kids and Alessandra
started digging into the world of
fortnight to find out just how addictive
this game is we've been hearing stories
through the glue of the world of video
games for over a decade of people who
start playing these online fantasy games
and just dive in headfirst and don't
come out the whole legal defense is
based around this case from 2015 where
three big tobacco companies were forced
to pay out massive damages because they
were not properly informing their
consumers about the dangers of smoke
drug makers are not responsible for
opioid addiction forget personal choice
to take the opioids is on the drug maker
alcohol companies cigarette makers like
this I mean we have had class-action
lawsuits that have actually proven that
then the companies settled all right so
now I'm gonna hit you with some numbers
the suit says that one of the children
identified as Ln has played 1891 games
of fortnight since December 3rd 2018 and
the other identified as Jay Oz has
played seven thousand seven hundred and
eighty-one games in a two year time
period that is a lot of Fortman and so
basically these two main case studies
the lawsuit suggest that epic games is
causing harm to its users by not warning
them of the addictive effects of its
game to form the framework for the
lawsuit at the beginning the lawsuit
identifies an addiction psychologist her
name is dr. Anita gaudiya Smith and she
made this claim in January of last year
that fortnight is similarly addictive to
cocaine and given that the World Health
Organization identified gaming addiction
as a diagnosable disease in September of
2018 a court would be able to rule on
gaming addiction the same way it rules
on drugs and so yeah you heard me right
according to this lawsuit we're
comparing fortnight to cocaine
that's somebody's chipper this morning
oh you guys are here all this time all
right so I'm gonna read you a section
from the lawsuit here when we play for
tonight our brain releases the pleasure
hormone dopamine and when a person plays
over a long period of time their brain
continually receives dopamine soon
normal levels of dopamine no longer
satisfy the brain anymore which drives
the person to require more and more
dopamine to feel good which has the
consequences that the person plays more
for at night in order to maintain your
dopamine and so of course this is what
would create a real addiction because
that hunger for that good feeling is the
exact same thing that causes you to get
addicted to drugs which seems at least a
little bit true but at the same time
isn't that also true about sex and
sports and whatever else you like to do
that makes you feel good I mean the
argument could be made that that makes
is addictive because you know they want
you to binge watch their shows and they
make all this great content so that you
just keep watching all right so I got a
little bit more reading for you the
lawsuit then goes on to describe how
this kind of effect can be harmful to
young people the effects of addiction to
video games including Fortnite on the
brains of children is particularly
damaging in when they are continually
attached to their machines they develop
severe gaps in their ability to
integrate in the full spectrum of human
emotions specialists report shortcomings
in vocabulary as well as gaps in social
integration indeed it is recognized that
the continued use of electronic devices
caused significant changes to the
prefrontal cortex of the human brain
changes that particularly affect young
developing minds so to put this into
normal people language this lawsuit
suggests that Fortnight can have similar
effects on a young person's brain to
drug use and that over time playing a
bunch of Fortnight can actually be
harmful to a child's actual brain
development other wild side effects that
the lawsuit suggests could be possible
when someone's addicted to Fortnight
include migraines back pain basic
hygiene deficiencies sleep disorders and
major social unrest basically every
stereotypical
gamer issue of all time the next point
in the lawsuit actually specifically
addresses V books and all the various
micro transactions that are obviously
very popular for the suit suggests that
this can be harmful to the finances of
young people and how impressionable they
can be with money they say that having
reward systems that encourage young
people to keep spending money can be
harmful it's like tantalizing to buy
that new next skin that everyone's
talking about
bullseye already have that skin did I
just get I don't even like harvesting
tools do I buy I said I was gonna buy
them all dang it all right fine
the harpoon this conversation is of
course not new at all and has been
pretty prominent in the gaming world
ever since these free-to-play games have
incorporated loot boxes as a way for
companies to make money and of course in
some parts of the world loot boxes have
been akin to gambling and have in some
cases been outright banned now of course
buying a new skin isn't exactly the same
as loot boxing it's not random fact is
we all know that feeling of wanting that
new skin it's just a couple bucks after
all one of the last points and when
they're describing how addictive the
game can be is how frequently it's
updated the fact is when fortnight
island changes every three months it
feels like you've never completed the
game and that way you stay home okay so
now that we've established what the
lawsuit says fortnight does to children
let's talk about how this is all gonna
play out legally alright so remember
that 2015 tobacco case I mentioned
earlier well that's the framework for
how they want this case to play out from
a legal perspective back in 2015 the
Quebec Superior Court ruled that three
big tobacco companies were not
adequately warning their users about the
health risks associated with cigarettes
before selling their products after the
case was closed
these companies were asked to pay back
billions in damages to the people they
were selling products to and to this day
they're still trying to pay back that
money and this is exactly what this case
against epic games based around these
two children's testimonies is seeking
out today that epic games has not done
an adequate job of warning its consumers
about what is an allegedly harmful
product before they make the purchase in
turn the law firm is also asking other
young people in Quebec to come forward
with their stories after listing all of
this evidence the lawsuit conclude
that this fortnight addiction is
violating the child's right to life
security and integrity as noted in the
literal Charter of Rights and Freedoms
and they go on to say that epic games
was knowingly doing this in order to
maximize profits let me tell you what
they say the defendants in order to
maximize the number of users of
fortnight and therefore maximize their
profits have knowingly and voluntarily
developed manufactured published and
marketed a dangerous product that has
been designed to create dependency in so
doing the defendants have unlawfully and
intentionally violated the children's
rights to life security and integrity
all right so that's a lot to take in
but at the heart of this we've got this
kind of funny but also kind of true
lawsuit the lawsuit says that epic games
made this game addictive and they even
tested it on guinea pigs to make sure
that it was and therefore under the
consumer protections Act in Canada epic
was required to let everyone know about
how addictive the game could be before
they even put it on the market they are
saying that epic used psychologists to
make Fortnight as addictive as possible
so after all this [ __ ] what are these
lawyers expect epic games to do well in
short pay up where's my money just give
me five minutes
the lawsuit asks for a tribunal to
assess all the damages that fortnight
addiction has caused in the province of
Quebec and then epic has to pay all
those damages back to those affected
they're also asking epic to pay back all
of the V buck purchases that these kids
made and continue to pay back damages
for those to anybody else that comes
flown and Wow all of this is absolutely
insane
of course we've all heard the sentiment
before video games they're addictive
they make us stay inside all day we
don't do our homework we smell really
bad
but honestly cocaine really you've never
seen this much cocaine in your life
that's gotta be worth what ten fifteen
thousand
I blew it thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification fell
for unique bite-sized videos you will
find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]